porte de versailles à paris jacques
chirac a inauguré ce matin le 34e salon
de l'agriculture
habitué des lieux lui même ancien
ministre de l'agriculture le président
avait passé près de cinq heures l'an
dernier à arpenter les travées du salon
reportage habitants berges agricole
c'est une tradition avec ses figures
imposées ces centaines de mains serrées
ses conseils ses encouragements jacques
chirac est chez lui au salon de
l'agriculture
chaque année c'est le même rite
on veut qu'ils ont peur
l'an dernier le chef de l'état a dépassé
5 heures au salon de l'agriculture de
loin l'inauguration qu'il préfère
pas moins de six cent mille visiteurs
sont attendus dans ce salon qui s'étend
sur 120 mille mètres carrés